la reine elizabeth était une vie bien vécue
une promesse avec le destin tenu
et elle est profondément pleurée dans son
décès
cette promesse de service à vie que
je renouvelle à tous aujourd'hui
je veux aussi exprimer
mon amour pour harry et megan
alors qu'ils continuent à construire leur vie à l'
étranger
et à ma maman chérie alors
que vous commencez votre dernier grand voyage
pour rejoindre mon cher défunt papa
je veux simplement dire ceci
merci merci
pour votre amour
et votre dévotion
envers notre famille
et la famille des nations que vous avez
servies avec tant de diligence toutes ces années
que des
vols d'anges
te chantent pour ton repos alors que mon héritier
William
assume maintenant les titres écossais qui
ont tant compté pour moi,
il me succède en tant que duc de cornouailles
et assume les responsabilités
du duché de cornouailles
que j'ai assumé pendant plus de
cinq ans  des décennies
aujourd'hui,
je suis fier de le créer prince de galles
pour siffler camarade
le pays
dont j'ai eu le
privilège de porter le titre
pendant une si grande partie de ma vie et de mon devoir
avec catheri  Ne à côté de lui,
notre nouveau prince et princesse de
Galles, je saurai
continuer à inspirer et à diriger nos
conversations nationales en
aidant à amener le marginal au
centre
où une aide vitale peut être apportée, j'ai
été élevé pour chérir un sens du
devoir envers les autres
et  de tenir dans le plus grand respect
les précieuses traditions, les libertés et les
responsabilités
de notre histoire unique
et de notre système de
gouvernement parlementaire,
comme la reine elle-même l'a fait avec une
dévotion inébranlable,
moi aussi je m'engage solennellement
pendant le temps restant, Dieu m'accorde
de respecter les principes constitutionnels
à  le cœur de notre nation
et où que vous viviez au
royaume-uni ou dans les royaumes et territoires à
travers le monde
et quels que soient vos antécédents ou vos
croyances,
je m'efforcerai de vous servir avec
loyauté,
respect
et amour
comme je l'ai fait tout au long de ma vie,
vous